massaggi già piccante il provolone le
olive
il secondo è il secondo la brace accesa
la lezione di zena questo vi insegna a
stare tranquilli non dovrebbe essere
così di non so ma io una volta andavo in
chiesa
oggi no perché mio joystick quello
vecchio ha sentito un sacco di cose anzi
non le ha sentite perché questo poi al
microfono integrato l'altro non appena
la sede meno male perché se avesse
sentito quelle rose mi avrebbe dato
veramente fatto da paesi non si fa si
chiama di non so allo ragazzi questo
gioco è il male nel senso che è fatto
benissimo però io mi chiedo se mi sono
sempre chiesto un giocato una persona
che non è un videogiocatore e magari
compra anche avreste su un 5 che sa di
un source come uno dei giochi
mi chiedo spesso dove può arrivare una
persona è impossibile io ho giocato a
tutti dark souls a blog l'on
quindi mi mancava solo non so se quando
il circo del pegasus
ecco perché non andate fattore mesi
prima perché dovete fare per playstation
5 bravi questo e marketing
quindi ho detto giocava l'unico capitolo
della frusta oftware chimica the demon's
soul questo 2 all sense è integro solo
perché costa 80 euro sono sarebbe già
distrutto comunque in questo gioco tu
muori sostanzialmente però arrivi a un
certo punto in cui fai dei mostrano
infatti due già il primo che si trova in
questo preciso punto l'ho fatto ed è
stato abbastanza semplice per arrivare
al secondo che si trova nel quartiere
dei cavalieri
bisogna percorrere un senso
che ironicamente si chiama il sentiero
del signore si chiama così proprio
perché in questo signore lo nomini
diverse volte c'è almeno nel successo
vediamo come la prima cosa che si che
devo fare innanzitutto e farmi evocare
un gioco tu puoi farti evocare per
aiutare altra povera gente che ha deciso
di rovinarsi la vita con demon's soul
per aiutarli io non posso più fare il
vostro che l'ho già fatto però se
qualcuno mi evoca llama fargli un culo
così e vediamo ci offre darian salve c'è
un sacco di gente 6 minardo le mie gesta
nel mentre che gioco ci sono molto
diverse volte che questa adesso va
avanti ma che non è quello di feng anche
se ci somiglia è molto più testa league
siamo arrivati a un punto dove sono
morti 60 volte aveva sentito qua c'è un
altro tizio che adesso spunta dall'ombra
era più avanti non me lo ricordavo ecco
perfetto adesso spuntano 5 fan i cani e
ti faccio un culo cosi 5 ed è una roba
obrobrioso perché per farlo ci ho messo
sei ore la prima volta perché devi farli
arrivare tutti di palazzi
bene bene con un capitolo di successo ma
i cani sono morti o andiamo
secondo me i ragazzi il vostro ce la
facciamo gli di perché siano abbastanza
bene nove prove siamo quasi arrivati in
realtà ragazzi al boss manca veramente
poco
e qui dietro però devo fare ancora un
tool devo fare ancora un ponte bello
lungo e quindi non è che arriva è
spuntata una pagina era pianeta che la
mia spalla è veramente grossa
maledizione non ho non so se la mia io
usavo all'altro ayane ecco taxisti io
usavo mai under negli altri vorrei una
simile perché questa un po grossissima
che non ha senso la salutare ho detto
italiano va beh allora siamo arrivati
alla parte finale del ponte che dopo
questa nebbia qua c'è sempre il drago
che fàcasino quindi attenzione
ok questo dovrebbe passare il drago e
fare un disastro nucleare adesso arriva
vedrete che arriva preparatevi appena
arriva accordiamo concludere vogliamo
perché lui ci spiana tutta la strada
elemento che passiamo lui non gli arriva
quindi riusciamo a farcela occhio che
sta arrivando io aspetto è quello grosso
l'avete seccata un altro ci penso io ci
penso io
madonna che giocatore è tutto a posto ma
con la natura o che la testa un po
lontana roditori che noi siamo giunti
alla né questa parte ecco per farvi
capire la difficoltà di questa parte ha
prestato a telese giando insomma questa
parte tutta quella che avete visto
dall'inizio di questo video fino ad
adesso
se tu muori te la devi rifare tutta
mia madre quando tornavo con i quattro
di matematico bisogna prima a far fuori
tutti gli arcieri di sopra e poi passare
a linux vado vado subito sopra falconi
carceri perché se non facciamo quali
quelli è impossibile fare con i numeri
fanno tutti quanti quindi facciamo fuori
questi e poi elezioni allora primo non
abbiamo fatto parecchio ci sono
facilissimi da far fuori area ci mette
niente però lui è un altro paio di
maniche
no uno è morto uno dei due è morto meno
male che non è molto quello che non sta
la partita perché sonora e avremmo
finito cioè non potremo più farlo al
posto perché se muore quello costa la
partita ce li manda tutti a casa
ovvio e ti pare no li ho fatti fuori
tutti i violini pure giu mancano ma che
porta proprio indietro
dovrei farlo come stesso occhio manca
solo lui seminiere a dare una mano libro
che fosse il tuo nemico
allora vi fate sia quando vi fa questi
attacchi non bisogna stare vicini stanno
dicendo quello mentre questa spada non
credo sia il massimo per poter imbarcare
potrebbe così so niente finché non cade
perché lui cade all'indietro
e quindi devo rispettare semita stiano
dietro non è il massimo da fare questo
ha sparato per evitargli un sacco di
colpi
però io ci provo e gli spacco le
caviglie e potreste darmi consigli senza
che questo sito
sarei molto ben ci dovremmo averlo
battuto una volta forte del mondo
vai ancora in 48 dai che mocio mason è
piatta
de vivo ma cosa ma non ha più vita
uccidilo cucino io cosa succede cosa
succede
siamo al gatto non è cosa chiede non
ragazzo è morto ma non è morto
[Musica]
però la cosa ma dove cosa succede a me
li ha dati punti ma ringraziando il
signore e il sentiero del signore
me li ha dati punti 9 che sono capace di
bard vero che i video vi sia piaciuto
scusatemi sarà un po porto ma sono
arrivato se vuoi questo box
poi non lo attendono fatti altri volevo
portarvi con compito di console spero vi
sia piaciuto forse i ragazzi si misura
sul momento è un mi piace gli scheletri
al canale alle pressioni
[Musica]